most of the Republican voters in our
newest polls say these allegations do
not make any difference to them Scott
McFarland spent the weekend talking to
some Trump voters and joins us now with
that part of the story Scott good
morning to you it seems that the Trump
voting base is very very very loyal
certainly this weekend Gail his defiant
denunciations of the prosecution Drew
Applause and cheers at rallies in many
GOP voters told me they hadn't read the
indictment that their minds were already
made up
he's a very strong candidate the more
charges they put on him the stronger he
seems to get we're having waffles for
everyone the support from many
Republican voters was unwavering as
Donald Trump made a campaign Suite from
Georgia to North Carolina they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
and I'm just standing in their way here
I am in our latest CBS News poll 76
percent of likely GOP Primary voters
think the indictment was politically
motivated what did you make of the
indictment of trump when you heard it
um the other Democrats are crazy and
trying to bully Trump trump supporters
said they're unmoved and their opinions
unchanged by the criminal case among his
Defenders North Carolina's Republican
lieutenant governor people are tired of
politics permeating everything and that
is permanent permeating uh into our
legal system I think people are not
going to tolerate that anymore the new
CBS News poll shows only 38 percent of
those likely Republican primary voters
consider it a national security risk if
Trump kept classified nuclear and
Military Secrets compared to 80 percent
for the rest of the country while 80
percent of Republicans said Trump should
be able to serve as president even if
convicted
at a rodeo in Oklahoma attended by his
closest rival Ron DeSantis this
Republican and Military veteran took a
different view when I was in the
military for 20 years anybody that
blatantly disregards classified
information well they should be held
accountable and uh if it was me that did
it would already be in prison
but that opinion was definitely in the
minority of what we heard overall this
weekend these legal cases are just going
to hang over the campaign with the first
debate set for August Gail
all right Scott more to come but is it
wrong to say when Donald Trump said
waffles for everyone I'm thinking that's
not a bad idea that's a policy America's
behind it yeah we're behind that thank
you Scott very much